Changer les mentalités dès le plus jeune âge
et cela tout au long du parcours éducatifs,
tels sont les grands objectifs inscrits
dans cette convention signée par tous ces
acteurs pour promouvoir l'égalité
entre les filles et les garçons,
les hommes et les femmes dans le système
éducatif et la formation à La Réunion.
"nous sommes accordés sur l'idée qu'il
fallait lutter contre les stéréotypes et
changer en profondeur la place de la femme dans
notre société et nous avons la conviction que
c'est dès l'école dès l'école qu'il faut ancrer
la culture de cette égalité dans les esprits"
Parmi les signataires, le Département s'engage
à la mise en place d'une politique éducative en
faveur de l'égalité au sein des collège.
Des actions seront également portées au
sein de l'académie des Dalons et par
le conseil départemental des jeunes.
"Les collégiens à partir de 10-11 ans, donc c'est
important d'avoir des clés de compréhension du
monde à travers tous les supports et tous les
formats qu'on peut utiliser. Effectivement,
la toile numérique et l'ensemble des outils
de de communication et des réseaux sociaux
doivent être intégrés effectivement
dans cette action de sensibilisation"
Cinq axes d'intervention avec
la mise en place de mesures
concrètes sont préconisées au sein de cette
convention. 31 actions ont été identifiées.
"La désignation dans chaque établissement
des référents et des référentes égalité donc
ça va essaimer quelque part la culture
de l'égalité. C'est par exemple l'appui
faite par le conseil départemental
auprès des collèges et des projets
collégiens sur un apport financier sur des
actions autour de ces sujets. C'est par
exemple la formation de toute l'équipe
pédagogique du rectorat sur cet axe."
Cette convention partenariale pour l'égalité
entre les filles et les garçons entre les
femmes et les hommes dont le système
éducatif à la réunion touchera un peu
plus de deux cent quarante cinq mille
élèves et étudiants. Une évaluation
sur l'avancée des actions et des axes
d'intervention sera faite tous les ans
afin d'identifier les situations les plus
sensibles dans l'engagement vers la parité.